très impressionnante manifestation des
partisans de l'école privée à paris les
organisateurs revendiquent eux deux
millions de participants à la veille du
sommet européen de fontainebleau les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement sont
d'accord sur un point au moins un échec
serait catastrophique
laurent fignon un tricolore le cycliste
breton a remporté cet après midi le
championnat de france sur route
et puis départ dans quelques secondes du
grand prix automobile de détroit
nelson piquet tu partages la première
ligne avec alain proch mesdames
messieurs bonsoir quatre cortèges qui
convergeaient vers la place de la
bastille deux millions de manifestants
selon les organisateurs 560 milles selon
un chiffre non définitifs du ministère
de l'intérieur qui n'avait alors
comptabilisés que trois cortèges
une chose en tout cas est sûre les
partisans de l'école privée avait prise
aujourd'hui possession de l'est de paris
une manifestation immense sans précédent
par son ampleur
des mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles
avaient été prises aussi bien du côté
des organisateurs que de celui des
forces de l'ordre de façon à éviter tout
débordement
c'était la principale crainte des
responsables du mouvement
pourtant tout s'est passé dans le calme
puisque depuis le départ du premier
cortège ce matin place d'italie
le film de cette journée avec dominique
loris premier acte de cette longue
journée le cardinal lustiger monseigneur
vilnai monseigneur honoré à forte aux
organisateurs le soutien des évêques de
france dans cette démarche il
manifestation nationale qui le serait
ni contre les autorités publiques ni
contre les formes diverses
d'enseignement reconnus en france mais
pour défendre une liberté qui nous est
essentielle un soutien plutôt discret
puis c'est le départ vers la bastille en
tête la direction de l'enseignement
catholique
chaque académie défilent derrière sa
banderole chaque école brandit sa
pancarte de la musique des chants des
slogans en faveur de la défense de
l'enseignement privé
mais ce qui revient comme un leitmotiv
tout au long du cortège
c'est la défense des libertés
en quoi
je sais pas si on fera quelque chose m'a
emmené tous tard si je n'ai pas la
liberté pour la liberté dans tous les
domaines pas seulement l'enseignement le
reste aussi
on vient nous dire tous les gens du
gouvernement ça ne change rien on vous
laisse la liberté on vous laisse tout
alors pourquoi ils ont fait une loi un
défilé bien canalisée par le service
d'ordre est une organisation efficace
sensibilisés par les rumeurs qui ont
couru ces derniers jours
un objectif pas de dérapage objectif
presque réalisé une journée
exceptionnelle dire à pierre daniel un
témoignage de fermeté mais dans la
dignité de vouloir conserver à leurs
enfants
le libre choix de l'école et enfin que
le gouvernement devant cette
extraordinaire témoignage sachent que
nous ne céderons jamais le passage des
personnalités politiques déclenché bien
souvent les applaudissements madame veil
monsieur chaban delmas jean lecanuet
jacques chirac entourée de tous les élus
parisiens de l'opposition
quelles sont vos fonctions vous donnez à
votre présence je crois que le sens que
tous ceux qui sont ici de c'est-à-dire
de vouloir se les parents disent
disposer de la liberté de choisir
l'école de leurs enfants
avec tout ce que ça implique ses dires
un hachoir réel est complet il s'agit de
cette fois-ci de la liberté
d'enseignement est fondamental ou comme
toutes ses libertés
car si on commence à grogner alors le
bras y passera et on se retrouvera dans
une autre société totalitaire dont nous
ne voulons pas
au soir de cette manifestation il faut
retenir plusieurs choses premièrement le
nom s'il est difficile de donner des
chiffres vous le savez ils seront
contestées on peut dire que c'est une
grande manifestation de masse les
organisateurs avancent plus d'un million
et demi de personnes
mais c'est un contrôle à le calme aussi
pour l'heure vous le savez pas le
moindre débordement
grâce à un encadrement très efficace
enfin si l'opposition était présente
aujourd'hui elle a su se montrer disons
relativement discrète voilà ce que l'on
peut dire
alors que la manifestation est loin
d'être terminée
jean-marie le pen et plusieurs milliers
d amis avaient annoncé qu'ils se
joindraient à la manifestation il était
donc présent rendez vous en début
d'après midi boulevard du montparnasse
une contribution très diversement
appréciée par les organisateurs
représentant les parents d'élèves
le reportage de bruno le dreff et
philippe mallet le cortège du front
national avait ses propres couleurs
un peu à l'écart de la manifestation des
défenseurs de l'école privée
jean-marie le pen arrive à l'heure à son
rendez vous en début d'après-midi ils
sont plusieurs milliers
au milieu les élus du front national au
parlement européen
ceint d'une écharpe inventé pour la
circonstance à ne pas reconnaître qu'il
s'agit d'une manifestation politique
quand il y a deux millions de citoyens
dans la rue c'est une manifestation
politique mais c'est normal
le cortège qui a ses propres slogans qui
chante régulièrement la marseillaise se
dirige vers la manifestation du privé là
on négocie mais ce renfort me plaît pas
à tout le monde
bon allez on n'est pas du tout d'accord
ils joignent à vous aussi uc500 à
l'intérieur surtout qu'ils veulent faire
entrer dans notre manifestation mais ils
sont pas là pour ça ils sont là pour
autre chose ils défendent pas la même
cause la liberté d'enseignement c'est
pas leurs problèmes sont ni pour autre
chose
15h30 boulevard du montparnasse jean
marie le pen et ses amis se glisse entre
deux cortèges de l'école privée intégré
dans le grand flou il reste néanmoins
tenu à l'écart
un service d'ordre très imposant dans la
manifestation vous l'avez vu au cours du
reportage de dominique fleury mais aussi
des forces de l'ordre présents aux
points stratégiques de la capitale
tout avait été prévu pour éviter que le
défilé ne dégénère c'est ainsi que tous
les ponts étaient contrôlés par la
police
paris coupé en deux d'un côté les
manifestants de l'autre les forces de
l'ordre quarante neuf compagnies de
sécurité cinq ans escadron de gardes
mobiles sans compter les gardiens de la
paix les ponts de la capitale
transformée en garage la police
nationale les brigades mobiles et les
crs 8000 hommes au total tout le monde
était sur le pied de guerre une
démonstration de force sans précédent
mais une démonstration de force
tranquille pour protéger les points
névralgiques de la capitale
l'élysée et l'assemblée nationale une
innovation complétaient le dispositif
classique
ces barrières anti-émeute qui une fois
déplié interdisent toute communication
d'une rive à l'autre
quant aux canons à eau ils n'ont pas été
utilisés
bilan 18 heures deux factions pour une
dissuasion efficace et 10 qasmi mais
sans effet sur les touristes les
clochards et les pigeons pierre mauroy
qui était l'invité de radio monte carlo
est revenu sur la manifestation il a
rappelé une nouvelle fois comme il
l'avait déjà fait hier que pour lui la
liberté n'est pas en cause
à travers la loi savary il estime par
ailleurs extraordinaire que les
manifestants d'aujourd'hui croix de
bonne foi défendre la liberté étant
libre en france de créer une école
privée
ma réponse est oui les parents sont ils
libres de choisir l'école de leurs
enfants la réponse est oui
les établissements privés sous contrat
conservait une originalité leur projet
éducatif
la réponse est oui le financement par
subventions publiques était garantie par
la loi
la réponse est oui la liberté des
communes et elle assuré la réponse est
oui
dans 9 à 11 ans celle qui estimeraient
que le contrat passé avec l'enseignement
privé n'est pas respectée pour
interrompre leurs versements
le financement de l'enseignement privé
serait-il pour autant menacer la réponse
est non en effet ces subventions qui par
hypothèse pourrait être remise en cause
disant ne représente que 2 5% du total
des sommes versées à l'enseignement
privé très exactement 500 millions sur
les 18 milliards que les écoles privées
bénéficient cette année au moins je le
dis pour que tout le monde le sache
veuillez valorise du radier alors
lorsque lorsque vous posez cette
question je veux bien
bien que monsieur chirac était pas
informé il savait pas du tout qu on
allait verser 18 milliard aux écoles
privées savais pas du tout que ce qui
était en cause c'est que dans dix ans
les communes puissent vraiment décidé de
ne plus verser si véritablement de
l'autre côté on ne fait rien ce qui
concerne la titularisation jeu bien
qu'il soit pas au courant mais enfin
c'est quand même curieux que monsieur
jusqu'à n'est pas au courant monsieur
chirac n'est pas au courant monsieur
bart n'est pas au courant et monsieur le
pen n'est pas au courant non plus et
c'est eux qui sont dans le cortège quoi
c'est demain que s'ouvre à fontainebleau
le sommet européen de la dernière chance
expression n'est pas trop forte après
les échecs des trois sommets précédents
à partir de demain les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement des dix devront trouver
une solution c'est maintenant très
urgent car faute d'accord les tests de
la communauté sont maintenant presque
vide
au moins pour ce qui concerne l'europe
agricole philippe sassier tout le monde
à bruxelles les persuader de
l'importance majeure de ce rendez-vous
de fontainebleau c'est un conseil dit on
plus importants que ceux qui l'ont
précédé ici même à bruxelles en mars ou
bien en décembre à athènes
d'abord pour une raison politique il
intervient juste une semaine après les
élections européennes qui ne fut pas un
succès pour aucun des partis politiques
au gouvernement
ensuite parce que cette fois ci un échec
serait bel et bien dramatique
jusqu'à présent on a géré la crise de
l'europe avec dix ont une certaine
sérénité
il n'y avait pas de décision trop
importante à prendre et surtout surtout
les caisses étaient pleines
or aujourd'hui elle menace d'être vide
et faute d'un accord à fontainebleau
bien la communauté ne pourrait pas faire
face à ses engagements financiers
notamment en matière agricole c'est
l'opinion qui exprime en particulier
gaston thorn
le président de la commission avant de
partir pour fontainebleau en répondant à
la question qu'est-ce qui se passerait
s'il n'y avait pas d'accord
pour moi ce serait très grave et
j'aurais tendance à dire que
pratiquement oui ce serait une
catastrophe car en octobre nous allons
manquer de moyens budgétaires et je sais
qu'il y en a beaucoup y compris en
france qui pense qu'ils auraient d
argent oui des arrangements sont
possibles mais à ce moment là je crois
que nous aurions à la rupture à la
cassure de la communauté existante et
qui aurait de la grande conférence pour
se compter pour dire est ce qu'on
continue à 10 à 12 ou seulement à moins
de 10 et ce sont là des hypothèses
comprenez que le présent la commission
même par l'usagé gars sont on estime
qu'un accord peut être trouvé à
fontainebleau mais chez les journalistes
spécialisés dans les affaires
européennes
comme chez les hauts fonctionnaires et
bien le camp des pessimistes est aussi
fréquenté que celui des optimistes voilà
nous allons tout de suite à détroit où
le départ du grand prix automobile a été
donnée il ya quelques minutes
avec déjà un incident je suis déjà ma
mère des trois dans quelques secondes va
être le donnait le départ du grand prix
et voilà ça y est c'est parti piqué
tremblements mal parti puisque mancelle
s'est intercalé il a soulevé la roue de
nelson piquet tu es à projeter la
voiture de piquette contre celle
d'alberto alain prost lui fort bien
parti était en tête et nous revoyons
maintenant l'accident avec la ferrari
qui va se frotter contre le mur et
nelson piquet qui a perdu dans le choc
la roue arrière et le capot arrière pro
celui est parti devant dès aujoud'hui
angelis en a profité pour passer non
seulement seul l'auteur un petit peu de
ce mauvais départ sur air qui n'a pas vu
lui est en partie très très loin la
voiture de nelson piquet tu rentres dans
la voiture de piquette
mais alors que la course n'a pas
accompli un tour les commissaires on
manquerait le drapeau rouge c'est à dire
que la course s'arrête immédiatement et
qu'un nouveau départ va être donné
alors ce qu'il ya c'est que bien sûr
nelson piquet tu va repartir toujours en
pole position un tour de moins il y en
avait 63 faire aignan
c'est 62 mais le problème c'est que
nelson piquet tu vas devoir partiront
volant de son mulet ce qui bien sûr va
l'handicaper nous renvoyer encore au
dessus au ralenti ce cet accident et
nous voyons que sur arc arrive de très
loin n'avait pas vu la voiture des
piquettes et que par contre il pas lieu
levitte de justesse nous entendrons a
d'étroites à la fin de ce journal
une découverte pour le moins inattendue
des enquêteurs après le démantèlement du
gang des postiches de la côte d'azur les
policiers ont retrouvé un carnet sur
lequel était noté toutes les longueurs
d'onde radio des services de police
spécialisés dans la lutte contre le
banditisme
les malfaiteurs pouvait donc agir
tranquillement en restant à l'écouté des
messages les concernant les enquêteurs
sont par ailleurs persuadé que les
truands arrêtés font bien partie d'une
bande qui agissait dans toute la france
sur place à nice isabelle bechler qui a
suivi la conférence de presse des
policiers voici cilic tortosa le pivot
du gang des postiches du sud est du
ressort territorial principal à l'issue
de sa garde à vue ce dimanche matin pour
être présenté au parquet lui et ses cinq
complices principaux vont être inculpés
de vol à main armée la police judiciaire
de nice a maintenant établi leur
participation à guy hold up
denis à toulon en passant par bastia ils
font pensent la majorité
tous fichés au grand banditisme depuis
des mois ils ont toujours opéré avec des
postiches des cagoules ou des passe
montagnes gantés armés de pistolet ou le
revolver de gros calibre bilan des
méfaits que la police leur attribue
depuis janvier 84 13 millions de francs
raflé aux banques et à leurs clients en
une trentaine de braquages mais les
policiers l'ont arrêté là qu'un des
noyaux de ce gang selon eux l'équipe
au total doit compter une trentaine de
membres au moins pour démanteler de
l'équipe l'appeler judiciaire a dû
mobiliser près de 120 hommes pendant
quatre mois
reste à savoir si la suite des
investigations permettra de déceler des
liens précis avec le gang des postiches
de la région parisienne
déjà on dispose de quelques indices nous
retrouvons temps dans la province que
dans la région parisienne la même
manière d'opérer les mêmes signalement
et
les éléments d'enquêté fournis et ouais
retenu depuis plusieurs semaines
démontrent notamment au niveau
d'utilisation des fréquences et des
scanners que des lieux cet avis entre la
province et paris ceci étant il restera
encore beaucoup d'investigations allant
de pouvoir établir qu effectivement ce
sont les mêmes membres qui ont procédé à
ces différents lieux
un beau coup de filet qui devrait se
poursuivre par d'autres inculpations
prochainement le moniteur du club
méditerranée qui avait disparu lundi
près des côtes libanaises alors qu'il
faisait en compagnie de deux camarades
de la plongée sous marine jean-marie mme
asselin a été retrouvé mort aujourd'hui
par un bateau grec
il a été tué d'une balle dans la tête
une affaire qui devrait faire beaucoup
de bruit puisque les deux compagnons du
moniteur qui s'était aventuré dans les
eaux albanaises
ses deux amis avaient affirmé l'avoir vu
se faire arrêter par les gardes-côtes
albanais il était vivant
à ce moment là un pétrolier grec touché
par une roquette irakienne près du
terminal de kharg en iran bagdad a donc
repris ses attaques contre les bateaux
qui naviguent dans le golfe
la trêve aura été de courte durée un peu
moins de deux semaines
c'est demain que s'envolent le troisième
exemplaire de la navette spatiale
américaine et se nomme discovery et
devrait permettre aux américains de
mener des expériences tout à fait
nouvelle dans l'espace pour la première
fois un pharmacien fait partie de
l'équipage ils devraient mettre au point
de nouveaux médicaments et de nouveaux
vaccins impossible à produire sur terre
philippe duez le troisième exemplaire
des navettes spatiales américaines est
un peu plus léger que les deux premiers
modèles mais il n'y a pas de grosses
modifications ce douzième vol sera
caractérisée par la présence à bord du
premier passager payant charleval caire
qui est chargé de faire fonctionner un à
paris pharmaceutique
signer à fabriquer un médicament dont on
ignore s'il s'agit d'interféron ou d'une
protéine spéciale la navette discovery
sera également chargé de placer en
orbite un énorme satellites de
télécommunications militaires
d'un poids de presque 8 tonnes les
astronautes testeront également de
nouveaux panneaux solaires beaucoup plus
puissants destinés aux futures stations
spatiales cinq des six membres de
l'équipage n'ont jamais volé dans
l'espace et un an après salir aïn une
deuxième américaine joue dirait smic va
tourner autour de la terre pendant sept
jours et 47 minutes
la nasa avait déjà constaté que la
présence d'une femme dans la navette
diminuer ou éliminer même le mal de
l'espace chez les hommes
cela va peut-être se confirmer leur
opinion en super forme à quelques jours
du départ du tour de france le coureur
breton était le plus rapide aujourd'hui
dans le morbihan où il a remporté le
championnat de france cycliste sur route
brigitte duvauchelle un tour et demi de
la fin pascal poisson est en tête
fortement encouragée par cyrille guimard
on se prend à croire que le vaillant
coéquipiers de fignon va l'emporter
il est talonné à 28 secondes par laurent
fignon et marc durand mais le vainqueur
du tour de france 83 apprend que pascal
poisson est victime d'une fringale
alors ils accélèrent la lure et part
seul à sa poursuite il le double ici
laurent fignon veut mettre fin à la
série des deuxièmes places
le giro n'est plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir il est en forme même s'il
grimace à l'issue d'une scène
championnat suspense il devient champion
de france en 6 heures 24 minutes 08
lutte acharnée pour la deuxième place
régis claire mène le peloton mais eric
dollars
pour la deuxième place suivi de pascal
jules bernard hinault termine 11e je
savais que je marchais était très très
bien que ce problème pourrait être la
déception l'italie mais je pense que
j'étais assez fort mentalement pour
l'oublier assez vite
aujourd'hui j'ai connu jean costa encore
le fortifier et non mes ambitions
prochaines ambitions pour le rang fignon
le jour une sa couleur préférée qu'il
espère bien un dossier au tour de france
qui commence vendredi prochain je vous
le disais hier soir le nouveau record du
monde de saut en hauteur féminin a été
battue par la soviétique
tamara biko va déjà détentrice du titre
elle a franchi 2 m 0,5
nous venons de recevoir les images de ce
record et brigitte duvauchelle nous les
commente un centimètre de plus et son
propre record du monde tombe deux mètres
0 savent pour la grande blonde tamara du
trop rare que ceux de suisse de 25 ans
étudiante en pédagogie révélé l'année
dernière en devenant championne du monde
à helsinki
actuellement la meilleure spécialiste
mondial du saut en hauteur une technique
parfaite une force explosive devant la
barre oui mais voilà pour cause de
boycott ils ne verront pas son sourire à
los angeles
rien de neuf à détroit où le nouveau
départ du grand prix n'a toujours pas
été donné nous ferons le point sur ce
grand prix de detroit de formule 1
pendant la mi temps des matchs de
football juste après ce journal une
mi-temps qui devrait intervenir aux
environs de 20 heures 45
vous avez un effet rendez vous ce soir
avec le ballon rond sur antenne 2 c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui explique l'horaire un
peu inhabituel de ce journal vous
pourrez suivre la seconde demi-finale de
l'euro 84 un match et qui oppose le
danemark à l'espagne on connaîtra à
l'issue de cette rencontre
les adversaires de la france pour la
finale de mercredi la france qui l'a
donc emporté hier soir face aux
portugais au terme d'un match magnifique
assorti d'un suspense à rebondissements
roger zabel
ce match c'était un peu comme un footing
on a
souffert pendant la satisfaction des
venu qu'après le coup franc plaisir du
but enfin inscrire ou jubile lille
domaine puis l'angoissent nous prend les
pulsations s'amplifie la déception de
l'égalisation de jordan
ensuite les premiers frissons de
l'éventuelle défaite le coeur cogne
merci plus tard les tempes battre
difficilement supportable jordao encore
lui le portugal mène pas de blizzard
c'est alors la chamade les français à
deux doigts du chaos
bats remercie on se fait alors à l'idée
d'une défaite mais l'espoir revient au
rythme du coup égalisation de domergue
le coeur bat de plaisir
deuxième prolongation une minute à jouer
insupportable surtout pas l'épreuve des
tirs au but le coeur ne tiendra pas cela
n'est plus possible on désespère puisons
s'auto place face à 220 à 66 stations
coup de coeur pour l'équipe de france et
ce soir danemark espagne sur antenne 2
les résultats du tiercé qui se courait à
longchamp dans le prix major fridolin il
fallait jouer le 17 le 18 et le 12
une combinaison qui rapportent dans
l'ordre pour 5 remplacer 6535 francs et
876 francs pour 5 francs placés dans un
ordre différent
miles davis est à paris pour deux
concerts exceptionnels au palais des
congrès sa prestation se termine tout à
l'heure ce géante de la musique noire
américaine ou même de la musique
américaine tout court est en général
très avare de ses propos il préfère
jouer de la trompette il était pourtant
tout à l'heure l'invité d'antenne de
midi dans ce studio
écoutez le parler de son art
ouais diez je reste quand j'entends le
mot jazz pour moi américain en amérique
c'est les blancs qui désigner le jazz
comme étant du jazz pour moi la musique
c'est de la musique jazz ça veut dire
mais gros pour moi c'est pas un mot qui
me plaît c'est pas un mot que je
supporte
tmusique oui très la musique qui
souhaite que nous jouons et 7e on parle
de son chalet de rang je dirais plutôt
que c'est de la musique sociale si vous
voulez au sens où c'est de la musique
d'aujourd'hui très mal et qui colle mon
nouvel album as la clique 1 comporte
toute une série de morceaux
la batterie électrique et c'est plutôt
une composition qu'un qu'un morceau
voilà tout ce que je peux vous dire de
la musique qu'on joue aujourd'hui parce
que il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de secret
il n'y a pas de formules associés
sous-tendant cette musique que nous
jouons aujourd'hui sur une musique
sociale savez on essaie d'éviter les
clichés en vogue et on est de ne pas
tomber dans tous les pièges rebattu du
vocal isme soit à paris au palais des
congrès et maintenant la météo avec
bougies de simonetta jusqu'à présent on
parlait des moutons de panurge mais
qu'en est il des perturbations à se
suivent et se manifeste tout de la même
façon les météorologues leur ont donné
non pas à des chiffres mais des lettres
nous on sonne à la perturbation est ce
qui sera suivie mardi de la perturbation
g et ainsi de suite
alors regardons sur la carte de demandes
que nous donnera ce f1 temps nuageux
avec des pluies intermittentes des côtes
de la manche des côtes de la manche au
berry à la vallée du rhône et aux alpes
du nord l'après-midi des éclaircies se
développeront éclaircies également
l'après midi à l'ouest sur le littoral
atlantique sur les pyrénées le massif
central
beau temps sur la méditerranée et la
corse avec toujours le mistral dont il
faut se méfier
le baromètre reste stable et le
thermomètre aussi depuis plusieurs jours
nous avons les mêmes températures de 17
à 21 degrés sur la moitié nord et de 20
à 26 degrés sur la moitié sud
demain lundi 25 juin le soleil se lèvera
à 5h sac 47 se couchera 21h58 et nous
nous souviendrons de salomon et le
dernier journal vous sera présenté à 22
50 par jacques séguin il recevra en
compagnie de roger zabel l'ancien
président du paris saint germain
daniel hechter demain vous rendez vous
habituel avec l'actualité 12h45 et 18h30
et je vous retrouverai quant à moi à 20
heures c'est à dire à l'heure habituelle
de ce journal bonsoir à demain